[Music]
not a free-for-all shift my weight and
turn right outside and goes or not first
and then it's gonna go anywhere my
shoulder was
yeah
[Music]
down the front arm then it turns at the
end if you see that that's where you're
escaping then you're gonna go back and
that's where the thumb and index finger
egg dishes rotate rotate out
thank you look at the difference I'm
following him oh we have no me to rotate
it I get much more action this one or
you're like how about you Buffett start
the circle already we're already going
on
for just the front cap
[Music]
so once I absorb here I'm in the circle
so this hand is now at the access point
and that's what I rotate around if I
have to move him there then this hand is
in the wrong place he's gonna activate
the deltoid and that meant this hand did
not complete his assignment so he should
be already past me okay don't go here
and then
holy cats so as soon as you feel the
pressure go off this and can go from a
parrying right into the carotid and
that's what you're looking for
see how I'm doing that I'm starting to
bleed what this hand is doing
once I know it's in the center it's not
doing any deflection is it's not
supposed to it can start to attack he
runs into the carotid while I am still
tough let me make sure you check his
height
[Music]
I want the in space the in space okay
and we're going to go a little bit more
dynamic
let's go I'm trying to take my body or
my Catoctin toady and I'm starting to
make it more dynamic you understand and
so your your unsophisticated
understanding of Joe Don test Abbate has
no translation okay so I'm going to make
it technique it was a grappling
technique and I'm gonna make it a
translate a transition to a more dynamic
technique okay but it has all the same
Yin space so on he has to be coming in
and then the same thing this pan has to
immediately start attacking but not hit
straight it has to allow for the hip
space behind the hand
let me which BBB now it does all the
time so I'm just going to that's all I'm
doing
I don't come here and go boom
I have to let him through
[Music]
right do you have a couple of things
they're doing it's very important sit
these are conditioning all that stuff we
can't define the scene use the soft
tissue building muscle connection
every time you torquing something you're
doing now okay this is not doing
anything and then of course you're going
to get more of an Aikido architecture
instead of you passing like two ships in
the night but when you don't have the
grab
would you just have that those
deflection angles go this is going to be
a straight arm and so if you're strong
enough you'll get it but you're not
doing like you don't know so the other
thing is if he has a weapon what was the
first position in the fight of my hand
outside the outside which is consistent
with weapon fighting so the first
movement is outside then the deflection
you see and there's no stopping up now
so we go we go slow I'm absorbing room
not like this slow right well you see
that difference
so boom absorb Oh once we get back cuz
right now even he's being influenced by
his by his training culture you're on a
grid so we'll go back to punching okay
and you're not gonna punch him out there
you understand so we're in here and he
goes to his punch do you think I'll have
to let him in so I'm here absorb absorb
and let it we're gonna start closer
right you could even be like old in one
one side do you understand so I have to
figure out all the technique you got it
you guys see where I'm at I just want
you guys to get away from everything's
out there and everything is linear so
it's not everything is a source do you
understand so for part of the time here
I'm going to have you keep that time
there you're not going to like it but
you're gonna have when you when you do
the circle you see it's works against
them so I'm in here
as I'm working on the great piece there
I'm gonna go to the back of him that is
there okay not only do you not get as
much reaction out of him you're not
conditioning your body for Coke you
you're making tactical poor decisions by
revealing your arteries and things like
that
but when he strikes you're not going to
be able to pull this thing do you
understand you're not going to go here
and then and get what you want like you
did in your beginner technique so I
caused a hook here you see and then I'm
rooting it I can't do that what made him
continue to go forward was that I
stopped the obstacles against him
do you understand that so the same thing
goes with when we're strike I don't care
what such same thing goes where we're
striking I don't stop him and then hope
that I'm gonna pull him in what I'm
going to do is move the obstacles out of
the way yeah I'm doing that but I am
shielding my arteries I have my anchored
elbows and I am very aggressive so you
can't shortchange it
you can't go here you shortchanged it
it's here same thing on this on the
other side it's just no same thing here
you cannot go here you have to go here
so here I am and you want to go you're
stopping him so then he's not going to
enter you get it and so all you're going
to do is have a clash which will work if
you're strong enough
instead lift the elbow up legend go
so you can make it just a force drill
stay there let's not fight anyone and I
go okay get rid of that energy that
contention point you see that okay stay
there now I have another contention
point right can you go forward no you
cannot go forward so get rid of that
contention point let's say you're my
first contention point
I like neutralize it second contention
point neutralize it you're gonna get a
third one here you see that
so I'm going to do that second one the
last one third one sorry with my body
so first contention point in my training
okay neutralized second contention point
with my training
okay neutralized and then the third
contention point with your body each
time he's allowed to go forward
right all around you know let's do it
keep it so one neutralized neutralized
this is the one that's getting the rest
of you you're like I Donna it's not
Aikido hey neutralize this last one by
turning the engine as you turn watch
what happens to this energy can you go
by me no okay so keep trying to go
forward yeah I'm doing that okay